good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it's my honor and privilege today to welcome
our speaker dr chongzhi zang from the center
of public health genomics at the university of
virginia chongzhi earned his bs in physics from p
king university in 2005 and his phd in physics
from the george washington university in 2010.
he undertook a postdoctoral fellowship in
biostatistics and computational biology at the
dana-farber cancer institute at harvard university
dr zang is an assistant professor in the center
for public health genomics at the university
of virginia school of medicine and he holds
faculty appointments in the departments of public
health sciences biochemistry molecular genetics
and biomedical engineering at uva and he is also
a member of the uva cancer center and the uva data
science at the uva school of data science chongzhi
is a computational biologist with expertise in
cancer epigenomics his research focuses on
algorithm development for high throughput
genomic data analytics and integrative modeling of
gene regulatory networks in mammalian cell systems
he and his laboratory are developing computational
and statistical methods for analyzing high
throughput data from innovative omics technologies
and using integrative data science approaches to
study gene regulation in mammalian cell systems
he developed several several popular computational
tools for chip seek data analysis transcriptional
regulatory inference and multi-omics data
integration dr zang's lecture today is entitled
integrative data science approaches for studying
transcriptional regulation in the genome and
as always we are streaming this lecture live
and for recording via youtube if you are watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are encouraged
to submit any questions for dr zang via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and
with that welcome chongzhi thank you so much for
doing this we really look forward to your lecture
all right thank you so much jack
for the very nice introduction
um so at the beginning i wanted to share with
you that i am actually an alumni from the
2018 cohorts of the biomedical data science
innovation lab um this is our good picture
from taken from a beautiful resort in band oregon
it was an extremely fun experience i benefit a
lot from it and also receive the most gorgeous
portrait of myself drawn by a fellow participant
so i look really look forward to
seeing each and every one of you
this year's participant in charlottesville uh in
a couple of months so uh today i'm going to share
with you about my research on computational
approaches and data science approaches
for studying transcriptional regulation
genome-wide so first of all i would like to
echo dr don brown's lecture from earlier this in
this seminar series about what is data science of
course data science is an interdisciplinary field
of research it lies in the intersection between
the three areas um so i changed this picture a
little bit specific to biomedical data science
so the the three areas uh that form the foundation
of biomedical data science includes uh myofan
statistics which is the quantitative science basis
and computation computer science and information
technology is the tool and engineering power
for data science and of course we we have the
important domain knowledge and as a subject of
research and the ultimate goal of doing all of
the data science research and in this particular
context is the biology and biomedical sciences
so data scientists require training and skills in
all the three areas nowadays although most people
who are doing data science research are usually
from one of the three backgrounds we usually need
some knowledge and some understanding
of all three areas especially biomedical
sciences as this is where the ultimate
problem and the solution are located um
so a another way of understanding data science is
to start from data and using computational other
quantitative approaches to convert the data
into information and connect them into knowledge
and to look for insights and eventually look for
new biology or new science from this data and
information so every step in this
process is involves new methods and
eventually we are going to our goal is to
make scientific discoveries from this data
so data science is the combination of data and
innovative computational modeling and meanwhile
where we also need to pay attention to the data
problem since they easily have overfitting and
over-interpretation issues that we want to
pay attention in the uh data science research
so i want to share with you um a uh a blog piece
from my postdoc mentor shirley liu uh who she
wrote this in a few a few years ago about levels
of bioinformatics research i think it also applies
to the general biomedical data science research
very well so there are different levels of the
research and just like if you uh have watched
uh kung fu panda a few years ago that would
start from the level zero um level zero is not
uh the type of the type of work that we actually
recommend is so-called modeling for modeling sake
um as this is as if you only have a hammer and you
are looking for a nail nails everywhere and and
this you need to get lost from this uh approaches
since you are not focusing on this particular
biomedical uh problem and then the level one is
to apply existing software tools to analyze new
data and to make new novel findings so this is a
start level of uh uh bioinformatics research they
focus on the particular biologic biology problem
and it's important to pick the right tool to
do the job correctly and this is also a good
training at the start point of biomedical data
science research and for level two is to develop
new methods uh for general data science
problem uh focusing on the research area um
the important thing is that the the tools
and the methods or models should be useful uh
to the field to the to the study of a particular
problem or to analyze one type of type of data
from a new technology and um they should advance
the knowledge in this area and they should be able
to to be used by other people in this field and
level three is to integrate in existing big data
in a smart way to make new biological discoveries
so this is uh really requires a higher level of
training and skills because the data is there
and the data are usually generated by others
and usually the data from multiple
different sources and the key is to
use a right and smart way to integrate uh
the data and to to make new findings that
cannot be seen by only looking at the one data
sets and of course the the the ultimate goal
is still to make new biological findings and uh
lastly is the level x it's the senior level uh
to make a bigger impact in the field is to provide
key integration and modeling to massive data from
usually from big consortium or team science team
science efforts and this type of work usually
includes the integration of all levels from one
to three so i i believe that successful data
science research or biomedical data science
research is probably doing all levels three
one two three type of work with the option
and opportunities to do some level x work
so after a brief introduction i want
to share you uh two stories uh of the
research work that my lab is recently doing
one story is a categorized as a level two
work is to develop computational methods
uh for transcriptional regulator analysis
and the other story is a so-called level
three work is we use the publicly available
data to study a transcription factor
ctcf this pattern in the cancer genome
so recently we celebrated the 20
years anniversary of the publication
of the draft human genome sequence the
completion of the human genome project
did not mean that the effort of
cracking the genetic code was done
on the contrary it only marked the start
of the modern modern genomics research
one of the most significant technological
breakthroughs in the entire biomedical
field in the past 20 years in my opinion is the
development of high throughput dna sequencing
techniques sequencing cost has dropped by over
1 million fold since the human genome project
dna sequencing technologies was not only used for
sequencing the the genome the human genome itself
but it has become a positioning or a profiling
tool to study many different elements and factors
associated with the genome and the genomics
has been involved to to the question solving
the question of tackle how the genome
works dynamically in different conditions
and how this genome can create
such a diverse cellular phenotypes
we in eukaryotic cell nucleus the genomic
dna is sophisticatedly packaged into the
structure of chromatin a number of protein
factors including histones with modifications
and transcription factor proteins that interacting
with dna and other chromatin remodelers
they all have the function of regulate
the gene transcription or gene expression
and the gene expression pattern uh in a
specific cell defines the cell identity
so the high throughput sequencing
technologies can help measuring the
genomic patterns of all of these information
in the genome for example the transcription
level can be directly measured by rna-seq by
measuring the rna transcript that generated
through the process of transcription and the uh
protein factors including transcription factors
and histomodifications can be measured by chipset
that usually marks uh the regulated regions
across the genome and in if we don't know what
particular factors to chip in the cell systems
we can measure the entire open chromatin by
dna-seq or ataxic and those enrich the region
from the data covers most regulatory elements
regardless of what specific protein factor
interacts there and for both chipseq and dna's
ataxia technologies they mark the regulator
elements not only in the uh promoter regions that
are nearby uh from a gene gene locus but uh there
are a lot of more are enhancer like elements that
are this uh in the distance from the gene itself
uh it's worth noting that uh the most
regulation events in human mouse systems are at
these distal enhancer elements and the protein
coding genes sequence only covers about
2 of the human genome and 98 of the genome are
non-coding including those elements for regulatory
regulation for gene expression and the chromatin
structure so the existing identified the existing
identified regulatory elements might cover
about 15 to 20 percent of the genome if not more
so as i just mentioned the chipseq and dna syntax
they can measure the genome-wide regulatory
profiles of some factors across the genome and uh
for chipseek it's it's measuring dna associating
factors and for uh uh dnase and the toxic they
measure the open chromatin profiles and they
they all use different uh biomed biochemical
assays plus and the high throughput sequencing
technologies so using the advanced emerging
technology we can generate a large amount of data
from this uh that that capture the information
from different elements in the genome that
eventually regards the data and to visualize the
data in in a certain way in across the genome and
an important work important role of computational
analysis or data science research is to decode
these data is to to convert this data back and
to to retrieve the actual biological meaningful
information even from the data to find a new
biology that that is currently unknown so my lab
develops computational methods and use this data
science approaches to study transcription so there
are two main types of projects that are that are
going on in my lab we classified it as a level two
and level three works are method development and
the data-driven discovery to identify new biology
for method development for this part methods there
are different levels of methods in my opinion um
so one uh so there there are model type of
methods and in this context the model means um
statistical models or math mathematical or
even physics models including machine learning
models so these are the basic
quantitative models that can
tell the connections and the relations of
different elements from the data and on top of the
model levels there are computational algorithms uh
that we can implement these models to to make it
happen and then on top of the algorithm level
there are we need also develop software tools
so that the entire community and other
researchers can use these tools and the
models or algorithms we developed for their
own research so we will first share with you
the first story um a method development story
about a computational method we name it as part
and you will know what it stands for in a
minute for transcriptional regulatory analysis
so um as we know gene expression determines
the cell identity and the uh regulation of
gene expression is important topics in
molecular genomics and genetics research
so gene expression profile or
transcriptome profile can be measured by uh
high throughput technologies like microarray and
more recently the rna-seq and even single cell rna
experiments a common practice of doing rna-seq or
gene expression analysis is further to identify
the differentially differentially regulated genes
from a experimental system we compare the control
and the treated or different conditions and these
groups of upregulated genes were done regular
genes are sharing the differential expression
pattern and in other cases we can use unsupervised
classroom approaches to identify clusters of genes
that are co-expressed among different conditions
this can be a large group of samples or even
different clusters from a single cell uh
analysis single cell data that means these uh
each different cluster each different groups or
conditions might refer to different cell types and
each class of genes may represent the genes that
are specifically expressed or active or regulated
in a particular group of cells so after identified
these gene sets that share the expression pattern
a common question we want to address is that
what transcription factors regulate such a
gene set with similar gene expression patterns
there are some common types
of approaches to address this
issue and all of them they will also they will
all have some uh limitations uh for the for these
existing approaches so first and uh foremost is
the ontology gene ontology based methods we there
are a lot of databases like gene set enrichment
analysis or genetology that you can characterize
the function of a group of genes but these this
is of course limited by the existing database and
the second type of method is a co-expression-based
method in which we use the uh clustering and the
network type of analysis to infer the regulatory
directions in the regulatory networks that usually
only depends on the gene expression data but the
expression of a regulatory factor does not always
means the regulatory activity of that factor and
the third types of method is dna sequence motif
based method uh in in which we what we usually do
is to look for the regulatory regions usually in
the gene promoter regions and to scan for the uh
uh highly represented uh sequence patterns uh what
we call dna uh sequence motifs and these sequence
motifs may give us some information of what
specific uh dna sequence specific transcription
factors are bind at these places to regulate the
gene but the occurrence of a dna sequence
motif does not necessarily mean that the
transcription factor is by transcription factor
binds there and in the human mouse and high water
organisms most of transcription factors binds
at distal enhancer regions which are difficult
to identify from the beginning and also it's
difficult to associate these distal elements
to their target genes as it's possible that
multiple enhancers can regulate in the same
gene in the same or different context and and one
enhancer can also regulate multiple target genes
so uh our the rationale of our approach the
approach we develop is to make use of existing
chipseq data which provides the direct binding
information of transcription factors in a lot of
different cell conditions and systems so since
the development of chipseek technology in 2007
there are increasing amount of cheapsick data that
are being been becoming available in the public
domain and then the numbers are also growing
a lot and i want to mention here that we we
probably heard that most of the uh most many of
the publicly available data are generated from
the large uh consortium like the encode project
or world map epigenome consortium but in fact
the data that are generated from this
consort here are only consists of less
than 10 to 20 percent of all the data that
are available in the public domain there are
thousands of labs are generating their own
individual data that are also available
so this this is there this is actually a
much richer data resource uh than we thought
so uh and this plot also shows the increase of
different types of histomodification histomarks
chipseek data available and
in in this particular project we take
advantage of several types of sequencing data
that includes we want to use the uh identify where
are the regulatory regions or possible enhancers
in this case we use the dna seek data since this
is from a few years ago and there are over 500
datasets from different dnac from different cell
types as in recent years a taxi has become a more
popular approach forced to profile accessible
chromatin and taxi data may maybe may have even
more data shortly or or probably already there are
more than a dna-seq and uh a second type of data
we use is to quantify the enhancer activity is the
chipseq data for one type of histone modification
h3 uh lysine 27 acetylation k27 saturation
data and because this uh histomodification
marks the activity of active enhancers from other
uh histomic histomarks and from this part you can
see the the amount of h3k27 acceleration data
are increasing faster than some other histomarks
probably because people are becomes more
interested in this factor that that regulates
the enhancer regulator activity and we also have
collected over tens of thousands of chipset data
for over 900 different transcription factors and
these are the data we want to use so our strategy
this method is to uh they are two-step strategy uh
in this method we name the bart which stands for
binding analysis for regulation of transcription
so the two set uh the first step in this strategy
is we give give a genset as input we first wanted
to use the dnac data and the hpk27 chipseek data
to infer a genome-wide cis regulatory profile that
mark the active enhancers that could regulate the
gene sets and the second step in this strategy is
to integrate this inferred cis regulator profile
with the over 13 000 data sets for transcription
factors to uh identify what transcription factors
are binds at binding at these enhancer regions
that eventually regulates the gene sets
so uh the first step of the regulatory profile
inference uh we in the first version we take
advantage of an uh an earlier model that we
we developed name the march that we always
love to give fun names to the tools and models we
develop and the idea is to convert the uh hundreds
of or over a thousand h3k27 chipset data from
different cell types and different conditions
um and to to give a quantitative measure
of the regulator potentials on each gene
and then use a regression approach to do a feature
selection and to select the informative uh samples
that can capture the regulatory profiles that are
specific to the input gene sets we are interested
as compared to the other genes in
the genome that we are not interested
so in fact later on we updated this method
uh with a different regression approach using
adaptive lasso and the this new updates is
actually the idea come from our discussion uh
at the biomedical data science innovation lab a
few years ago with a fellow participants in the
in the innovation lab professor yang chen who
is a statistician from university of michigan
she suggested that uh adaptive lasso might
be a better approach of uh addressing this
and indeed we updated this uh method
uh in our recent new version of bart
and the second step is to associate the inferred
cis regulator profile with the tens of thousands
of chipseq data and to identify which data sets
and which transcription factor that have the
binding profile that are most associated were most
similar to the cis regulator profile and we use
several additional steps of integration and remove
some background and to get and add additional
levels of history tests to give a integrative rank
of all the transcription factors that have chipset
data and eventually we will make the prediction
by saying that the highly ranked transcription
factors from the other from the entire list are
are predicted or inferred to be the most likely
transcription factors that regulate the target
gene sets and uh we compare some of the existing
methods for uh for the transcription factor
inference some of them are using the motif
based approach including homer and some others
are also use similar chipseq database approaches
to evaluate the performance of these different
methods um the evaluation is done in data from
a database called noctf in which they contains
the genius differential expression data from
a knockdown or knockout of some transcription
factors and we say if we don't know what the
transcription factor it is if we only fit in
the uh their differential expressed genes whether
we can correctly predict the true regulator that
was knocked down to generate that data sets
and in they include the database includes
over 500 data sets for about over 300 different
transcription factors and for both the data data
sets number of data set level and the number
of factors level uh the our new version of bart
in the web version called our web uh outperforms
uh several other existing methods also outperform
our our own earlier version of bart in identifying
the true factor from the knockdown data sets
then we also thought about if this tool can infer
the transcription factor that are associated
with any a regulator profile it may be also be
able to apply it to other type of genomic data
if we also want to be interested in
the transform factor association so uh
recently we developed a a variant version of
this uh of bart we named the bar 3d 3d means
the 3d genome data and the goal is to identify
the transcription regulators or transcription
factors that are associated with differential
chromatin interaction from a differential high c
data analysis so high c measures the uh chromatin
interaction across the genome that can help us
build up the entire three dimensional structure
of the of the uh genome and chromatin structure
by comparing uh two high c maps the goal
here is to first identify the genomic
regions that have a differential different
level of interaction with their nearby regions
within a certain distance boundary and then
to infer the transcription regulators that
are associated with this differential chromatin
interaction profile so then we test this method
and it looks like it works well um identifying the
right transcription factors that are knocked down
from the from the either the knockdown or
deletion of transmission factors um the uh
knock down the transform factors and the high cd
that generated afterwards and uh we found that
the bar 3d can not only identify the factors uh
that were that were knocked down or knocked out
but they also identified some other interesting
factors that are either can be proved uh were
needed further validation to be also play a role
in this process of changing the uh chromatin
conformation structure so as a result we integrate
all of these several tools uh we developed into
a large system including a web server that can
provide the analysis by any user even for a non
computational biologist once you get your gene
set you can simply do the analysis from uh from
this web server yourself so this uh bart's tool
can accept a multiple type of uh inputs include
a gene list uh that was designed in the beginning
and they also be a chipseq profile if you want to
identify what other cofactors or other factors
that are close to this chipseq profile or even a
taxi profile and it it can also accept any region
from the genome and they can tell you what factors
binds there more likely than another method
and high c hi-c maps use the bar 3d approach so
so we hope that this tool can provide a
alternative or complementary approaches to
other existing methods like including dna motif
scan so hope these two can help your studies of
the functional regulators to explain or interpret
your differential gene expression uh data or
and or other type of genomic profiling data
so then we we want to look for the uh somehow
find some application of the bar to ourselves
so one effort that we did recently is to
uh predict the active transcription factors
in a cancer type using the existing cancer
transcriptome providing data from the cancer
genome atlas or tcga because of the limitation
of the availability of primary tumor samples
tcga does not provide any chipset data that
measures the actual actual regulatory profile
from this from this cancer patient but tcga has
rna-seq data measuring gene expression so for each
and every cancer type we simply did a different
did a differential expression analysis to identify
the cancer comparing the cancer samples with the
normal samples to identify the differentially
expressed genes up regular genes in cancer and
downregulated genes in cancer and then run the
bart analysis to to take to integrate the
information that we we we have from the bart
from the large amount of data from the public
domain to use the public data to infer the
possible transcription regulators
transform factors that plays a role
in the uh cancer gene regulation and
this is actually done by a very talented
undergraduate student in my lab zach thomas
and he processed all of the data from tcga and
display this data to the public domain in a data
database as a resource and in in this way we can
browse or look for the activity of
each and every transcription factors
in in the that are that have chipset data
so for example if we look at uh the pattern
the tf activity pattern of one transcription
factor in this plot we are plotting this uh
part a prediction score for for for this
factor for in each and every cancer type
and we also compare to a earlier uh another
similar uh approach that using a different similar
work but using a different approach to infer the
transcription factor from cancer and that's a work
from a cis from cancer database and by integrating
these two elements it also included the including
the expression level of the transcription
factor itself we can see that if this
this is a big circle in the top right which means
that they have a high score in both measurement as
well as a high expression uh level of this factor
in a colorectal cancer type which means that this
transcription factor may play a role in this
cancer type that so this can be useful uh in the
study of each and every cancer type and useful for
study the activities for each transcription factor
and we are very happy to uh share with you that
after the publication of this uh methods there are
there are other labs who are using our tool bar
tool to find the important transcription factors
in different cancer systems and they have a very
good public work publications in including nature
and another work in uh this is from another
lab at uva uh uh studied uh geoblastoma and
this work actually got a semi-finalist
in the recent stat madness competition
and we are very excited that uh the computational
tools that we developed can help other biologists
in their studies so as a quick summary for
story one we developed this tool called bart
it's a regulatory factor transcription
regulator identification method
and we leverage a large collection of publicly
convertible chipset data to build the model and
they can be applied for analyzing multiple
type of data and eventually we developed
open source software tools and web servers and
database resources uh with application to cancer
research hope that these tools can be helpful
uh for any researcher who are interested in the
transcription regulation as well and next i'll use
a few minutes to share my second story level three
data-driven discovery star story about
the city cell pattern in the cancer
genome as i mentioned briefly that the genomic
dna is organized into in a hierarchical chromatin
structure in the eukaryotic eukaryotic
cell nucleus and the three-dimensional
uh hierarchical structure includes the
multi-megabases size the compartment a b
compartment and hundreds to megabases 100kb or to
megabases size the topological associating domains
or tags and numerous smaller chromatin
loops so ctcf is a protein dna binding
protein or also categorized as a transcription
factor that binds in the dna and they can it
can induce dna looping with cohesion complex and
other proteins such as mediators it binds at most
test domain boundary regions and has an important
function in maintaining the chromatin structure
and the higher water topology so cdcf as a
transcription factor is is the very factor that
connects the local level transcription regulation
and the larger scale chromatin structure so
that's why we're specifically interested in the
pattern and behavior of this transcription factor
and we found that city cell binding is usually
very stable and conserved across different cell
types in the human genome this is expected
because they it bounced to maintain the
relative state stable chromatin
chromatin structure so we compare
uh the quantity accessibility profile from uh
dozens of cell types from the encode consortium
and uh we found that the variation of chromatin
openness at city cell binding size is actually the
smallest as compared to uh the other non-promoter
or enhancer regions and the promoter regions
so for such a stably bind protein a disruption of
cd cell binding size can be very dangerous to the
dangers to the cell it can change the chromatin
conformation and interactions that alter the gene
expression pattern so existing works usually
attribute the cd cell binding alterations
to dna sequence mutations and
the dna methylation changes
as many individual cases have been found in
the cancer and developmental diseases however
we wanted to take a look at the bigger picture
view of the cdcf binding landscape and look for
general pattern of city cell binding alteration
in the whole genome and the different cell types
city cell binding can be measured by chipseek
across all different cell types we collected over
800 public available chipset data from hundreds of
human cell types including both normal tissues and
disease including cancer cells from this snapshot
we can see that across different cell types some
binding sites are very conserved and some other
binding sites are specific to several cell types
so we kept over 700 data sets that are have
high quality and merge all the bindings identify
binding sites um together in and generated a whole
repertoire of uh possible city cell binding sites
in the genome that includes that have over 600
thousands of unique regions in the genome that
can have city cell binding in any uh cell type
and then we look at the for each binding size we
look at the occupancy score meaning that how
many of the data sets where there is a peak
at this region and then we look at the
distribution of these occupancy scores
for all the city cell binding sets we can
see that the majority of the binding sites
are specific to a field data sets they are cell
type specific binding sites where on the other
side of this curve we observe an elevated
tail there is a group of binding sites that
are stably occur in almost all data sets uh
imagine a background where city cell binds
randomly at different sites in different cell
types the expectation of observing a peak
binding sites with certain occupancy scores should
decrease drastically when the occupancy score
increases then we use a parallel function to
model this background and we can see the number
of conserved the size are much greater than
expected by chance so we define these group
of binding sites or constitutive binding sites and
they are the group of binding that are marked at
topological associated domain boundary regions now
once we have all the c cell binding in the human
genome we want to know if there are any binding
sites that are specific to one cell type and in
this context we are interested in a cancer and
we use one cancer type t-cell acu lymphoblastic
leukemia as an example to show our approach in
our collection we have eight chipseq data sets
from the tll cell lines and we compare the
reg the occupancy score of all the over 600
thousands binding sites in the
genome and plot this distribution
according to their occupancy
score in the eight tll
data sets whereas the occupancy frequency in all
the other uh 763 data sets so the the the for each
elements uh the dance represents the number of uh
chipset binding sites that belongs to this group
so we are specifically interested in two groups
of city cell binding events one group is that
the constitutive binding site which means that
they are conserved in most uh cell types the
binds there but specifically lost in tll um has a
very low occupancy score in tll and whereas the we
define this group as a putative lost site and
on the other uh side we defined another group
as putative gain set which means that they are
very cell type specific they don't bind in most
cell types but very conserved conservatively
bind in the t cell leukemia data sets
and we also make sure that these for for cancer
studies we also make sure that these gain and
loss are indeed uh have different level comparing
the cancer versus their match the normal cell type
to make sure that they are indeed cancer specific
not but not only cell type specific using using
the similar approach uh we we can we are able to
identify such uh binding gain and binding loss
in every cancer type that have enough available
data including leukemia breast cancer colorectal
cancer lung and prostate cancer so because most
of the existing chipset data are generated from
cell line models we want to make sure that this
binding size actually occurred in the actual
cancer primary tumor patient cancer patient data
so not artifact from the cell line but uh as we
know most we don't have uh cheap sequence data for
cdsf for most cancer patients but we know that the
chromatin accessibility are positively correlated
with the city cell binding so we take advantage of
the available toxic data from the tcga to see if
the city cell binding loss again also potentially
occur in patients so the idea is that we
identified those uh again inside and we look at
their differential quantity accessibility levels
comparing in the cancer and the other the other
samples uh in as control indeed we found that
these identified cancer specific again loss events
show a different differential level of quantity
accessibility in the primary patient samples that
indicates that this unique loss organ city
cell binding events are not only from cell
line but also occurred in primary cancer
so then we wanted to ask whether these
specific binding events correlate with other
features in the genome so use the our developed
by 3d approaches that can measure the differential
quantity level we found that the gain and the loss
of citizen binding positive associated
with the gain and the loss of chromatin
while the elevated or decreased
chromatin associating interaction levels
uh comparing the cancer and the normal
cell type and um we also found that uh
as previous studied the loss of cdcf binding
largely correlated with the increase of
dna methylation at the binding sites also using
the public available dna methylation profiling
data but interestingly we found that the dna
methylation again of dna methylation for loss
of binding but the loss of dna methylation can
only explain only a portion of the again the
city cell binding they don't explain most of
them um so now we wonder why uh are those uh
binding sites specifically gained in this cancer
type whether there are other factors that could
induce this event so from the gender binding sites
we identified we first did a motif scan but we
did not find any other interesting motif other
than the city cell motif itself and then we look
further in across the genome by using the high
c data and we look at the regions that have an
increase in interaction with again the cdcl sites
and then did use the bart the tool here here comes
the application of the bar 2 to identify what
possible transcription factors are enriched
in these regions and interestingly we found
several transcription factors that are
known to be the oncogenic transcription
factor in this specific cancer type uh
with the help of our instrumental collaborators
we validate our prediction or to study what's the
role of this transcription factor namely notch
in the in the occurrence of a city cell binding
sites that are specific in this cancer type so we
perturb the notch by creating a notch off and not
on states using a gamma sequence inhibitor and to
remove this inhibitor and once the notch binding
is removed and and and regained we wanted to
see whether the identified again the cities have
also changed and indeed we found that after
knowledge is removed most of the gang the city
cell binding decreased and after knowledge is
rebound most of the decreased city cell binding
regained their binding in in the in the cancer
site this means that um the perturbation of
this transcription factor can result in the change
of the city cell binding on the other hand we want
to address whether the gain binding city of cdcf
is required for the transcription regulatory role
of the notch the transcription factor in this
cancer type so we knock down cdcf using shrna and
generated the rna-seq data to look at the
expression and if we use bart to identify
the possible regulators for the differentially
expressed genes after citizen have knocked down
the top in which the factor are actually
not which means that once you knock down
cdcf notch target genes are downregulated
as also shown using a privately identified
large target gensets this means that indeed
cdcf binding is required for the oncogenic notch
to activate their notch target genes
so although we did not observe a direct
protein protein interaction uh between cdcf and
the notch um so we uh so so this this process
is probably not a conventional recruit protein
recruitment from one to another so we further
proposed a model this largely still speculative
and as a hypothesis that can be tested further
that we we found that uh our well
i mean our uh uh idea is that
the function of knowledge a function of
cdsf in this particular cancer cases is to
facilitate the formation of a transcriptional
condensate with the super-enhancer regions
for transcriptional activation so notch
can be recruited by this large condensed
transcriptional condensate induced by some
transcription factors including notch that
that is known to induce silver enhancers with
other cofactors and chromatin remodelers to create
this very active uh transcriptional activation
stat status to to make the transcription happen
so as in summary for the second story we use
the integration approach and take advantage
of over 800 publicly available chipset data and
also integrated with other genomic data most of
them are available from the public domain and we
found the interesting pattern of cdcf binding in
the genome of cancer cells and we we found that
dna mutations or dna methylations cannot explain
most of the cities uh cancer-specific gand or lost
city cell binding events we observed in cancer and
possibly the cancer-specific gandicity
cell binding has a role of facilitating
the oncogenic transcription activation
by contributing to the formation of
transcriptional condensates with super enhancers
so by sharing with you these two stories i hope um
we well i've convinced you that our approach of
doing data science in genomic research and using
data science innovative data science approaches we
can change the olmics studies that were criticized
you used to be criticized by cindy brenner
a long time ago as low input high throughput
no output but become but change this to a real
precision science for position medicine research
so last i would like to thank the
people who actually do did the work um
my lab members and especially my postdoc zhen
zhaowang and my former student benji ma and the
current undergrad students zac thomas who
did most of the works for developing bard
bio3d and the bar cancer resources and
zhenya wang also did all of the work for
the in the uh citizen study and also i want to
thank my collaborators uh including uh a panel
since their crystals from northwestern who
helped us the experimental part of the cdcf
project and yangchen that i mentioned we met at
the biomedical data science innovation lab and she
gave us important ideas of improving bart as well
as other collaborators and my funding agencies
and i want to mention that we receive the support
from the jktg foundation as a as a seed award as
an outcome from the data science innovation lab
that helps the development of this research um all
right so this picture was taken uh before
the pandemic and we really hope that this can
we can get this pandemic over with pretty soon
we can meet each and every with you in person
very soon with that uh thank you very much for
your attention i'd like to answer your questions
you have any questions you may have zhang
zee thank you so much that is a fantastic
amount of work uh really what you're doing
there with these computationally intensive
techniques for looking at transcriptome factors
is uh really quite amazing and it's fantastic
that you have these resources that you've built
um like bartcancer.org in places where people
can actually take their own data or data
that's publicly available and analyze it
just a couple of questions for you how speaking
of computationally intensive how computationally
intensive are these types of analyses and and how
do you do it do you do it on local machinery and
in your laboratory or could one do it on local
machinery or do you have to use large-scale
high-performance computing or cloud computing
what do you recommend good question so um
most of the work that we are doing is using high
performance computing that are available to us
in the from from from uva and some of the basic
analysis of the data can be done uh using a local
computer but i would highly recommend using high
performance computing to for for all the model
model building and model training a lot of these
type of work um they may be too too intensive for
a laptop um so this this is actually our the
motivation of for us to create a such a web
server for the uh for the general users to use uh
uh the tools because uh not everyone is uh uh have
has access to this high performance computing
resources and we want to make the the tools uh
as accessible as possible so the the the
web server we build up connects it has a
front end of a web server but connects to the
high performance computing in the background
so when when the actual user submitted the job
to the web browser web server they actually
the hbc will do the computing for them and
generate the results to the users in a fairly
small amount of time and i want to say that
this is this is after a large amount of work of
model training and the data cleaning up so
that takes some may perhaps take more time
so we already compress the data into a form
that will only require the minimum amount of
hpc resource are there any special things that
people would need to know in order to kind of
get started using these tools or is there any
any specific data science they need to know
yeah well um as i briefly mentioned in the
beginning um in order to understand how
how the tools work uh the only one
only need to understand the basic uh
statistics and some machine learning um that's
that's all they need but if we simply want to
know the get the results from a data for analyzing
your data we our goal is to to make it uh anyone
can use so even if you you don't know any data
science you don't have any data science background
but you have the specific biology question
you have the data and you can generate
the results yourself of course understanding
the background will be helpful for interp
data interpretation but that not that's not
specifically required for using the tool itself
chongzhi zang from the center for public health
genomics at the university of virginia thank you
so much chongzhi really appreciate you sharing
your amazing amount of work with us and telling
us about these tools and fortunately for me i
don't have to understand any of it i can just
start going to use it i hope that others find them
also equally uh useful for their work um thank you
again chongzhi everyone have a wonderful
weekend and we will see you all next week
thanks again bye-bye thank you very much jack
and thanks everyone for your attention bye-bye